the whole Snow White fairy tale is
really about home invasion and burglary
this woman barges into the home of these
clearly mentally disabled old men
chimney crickets who aren't even half
her size what a cute little chair now
eventually the dwarves grow attached to
her so you might say oh they're friends
they were terrified when they first got
out like anybody would be you get home
and there's this giant like sleeping on
your bed all of your beds anyone would
be scared eventually this kind of
Stockholm syndrome takes effect and they
become friends and then when she dies
they put her in a glass coffin because
they somehow had a full-size glass
coffin lying around which makes you
question their motives frankly and they
display her body for several days until
a prince who has never met her before
okay shows up out of nowhere kisses this
woman who for all he knows has been dead
for days nothing was done to preserve
the body and he starts just kissing this
dead woman it's very dark it's a very
morbid story when you think about it
like an insane person